I think the message for me is always
this we all know somebody that has
cancer or that's died from cancer we all
know a grandparent or have a friend that
had a grandparent that's battling
Alzheimer's we all know people that have
suffered or died from heart disease we
all know children that need three
injections of insulin every day these
are all we're all aware of the ravages
of hiv/aids so what our industry does is
we attempt to develop medicines to cure
these terrible diseases and if we can't
cure them
maybe we can alleviate some of the some
of the suffering that is righteous work
and so it's easy to maybe come up with a
smear campaign about our ads or about
the cost of drug discovery drug
discovery is expensive because the
technologies we use are expensive drug
discovery is expensive just because for
every one drug that's discovered there's
a hundred that have failed so what I
would say is what we do is by developing
drugs medicines that make the world a
better place that's just a wonderful
thing I think to do as a technology as
an industry it's rewarding work
I think it's more than just my work you
know you always want to have integrity
and feel good that you came to work and
gave it your best effort day in and day
out that in of itself I think is
important but I want to be known as a
good father a good spouse a good husband
a good friend someone that always kept
their integrity someone that always
tried to help others that were less
fortunate that themselves I would think
that would be that someone that lived
life to the full every day I don't know
proud of it but I think what I'm very
appreciative of it was awesome to have
the opportunity to meet our CEO Jeff
Kindler that was really awesome that he
would come visit the lab guys that was
really cool and to have the opportunity
to explain to him this is really what we
do isn't that amazing
that was an awesome opportunity to be
recognized for our work for the wave
bioreactor which is now used all
throughout discovery and development and
here at Pfizer that was a I think a
wonderful achievement and it was
something that it was a simple new
technology that we were able to expand
accross Pfizer to be recognized for that
that was very awesome to be fortunate
enough to meet my wife here at Pfizer
after that story I told you of my first
wife dying from breast cancer how
fortunate was that to find someone else
who was just loving and caring and kind
how many people get that opportunity to
win twice in life that's very fortunate
to be able to work with some of the most
brilliant people in the world in their
areas of study that's pretty fortunate
so I don't think I'm I don't think pride
is the word I think I recognize how
fortunate I am and
so for that I'm thankful I think in some
ways Pfizer is attempting to do that
through the science and math are really
terrific program through the Sam Jam
program one thing that we did a lot of
earlier my career was bring many of
these high school students through the
labs into some of the labs to actually
see the technologies where they could
kind of interact with the student
because of I think because of safety
concerns now you know we're much more
litigation society because of the cost
involved perhaps we don't do that as
much as we should but certainly we
should be bringing in the the high
school students to the cream-of-the-crop
high school students and the AP biology
ap chemistry students from high school
so that they can see these technologies
because you know to read about them is
one thing to read about chemistry or to
read about biology but to be able to see
it in action that's just incredible and
that's you know that's what happened to
me you kind of get to see it in action
you know that enthusiasm is infectious
it generates that gee-whiz response
which is really what we want and so I
think that we need to invest more in
certainly our high school level kids are
college level kids we do quite a bit at
the middle school level but certainly to
invest more because they are the future
scientists of tomorrow
you